kennedy tonight as america's radical new
green deal
democratic socialists yearn for their
marxism
socialism the people of cuba who have
been suffering
under this very ideology for decades
falsehood false promises everybody will
share in the wealth never worked out for
decades
they're now risking their lives in
search of freedom something we often
probably
all take for granted it's no secret
under castro's murdering marxist regime
the cuban people have long faced dire
shortages of food and other basic
supplies
even toothpaste medicine soap there's a
reason they're still
driving cars from the 1950s barely held
together by like string and super glue
everything from energy to eggs it's all
rationed
every cuban citizen is only allowed five
eggs a month that's it needless to say
the quality of life in cuba
outside of the ruling elite they do
great
it is abus abysmal and during the
ongoing unprecedented nationwide protest
in cuba demonstrators they're not
calling for more eggs and more rice
instead they are chanting freedom and
down with communism
they're carrying cuban and they're
carrying
american flags yep you know the same
american flags that
we watched on the fourth of july and we
see a lot we saw it last summer
many leftists in america trash yeah
those american flags
even in the face of a massive government
crackdown with mass
arrests risking lives cubans continue to
take to the streets
risking their lives every minute in the
process
many likely will be murdered as a result
of this
these brave efforts that they're
involved in back here at home in the u.s
all america's top radical socialists
they are well predictably yet eerily
silent lifelong communists you know the
guy that
honeymoon in the former soviet union
bolshevik bernie sanders
praised castro's literacy programs and
frequently attacks republicans
he's been completely silent about the
ongoing demonstrations in cuba so
senator do you stand with the people of
cuba for liberty for freedom
congresswoman ocasio-cortez the real
speaker of the house missing in action
the left social justice warriors they
too are missing in action
even still tonight one time back up
quarterback turned woke
profiteer colin kaepernick see him right
there decked out in his
fidel castro shirt he doesn't seem to
care about those that are now crying out
risking their lives for freedom in
communist cuba
colin by the way the guy in the shirt
that you're wearing in that picture
right there that guy
yeah he was a ruthless mass murderer
colin maybe that's something to take a
knee about maybe
show some solidarity for cuba's freedom
movement that's going on so far it's
crickets
one new york times columnist claiming
quote shouting
freedom and other anti-government
slogans freedom
and other anti-government slogans uh
poorly awarded you think
thousands of cubans took to the streets
uh
other anti-i can't get over that freedom
and other anti-government slogans
and the new york times i guess freedom
is an anti-government slogan
that shows you how far they've sunk in
the sewer anyway
no this is a call for human rights in
other words we talk about rights we
believe in this country
we're endowed by our not thing but god
the creator of everything
natural god-given rights not government
rights
in the face of a tyrannical communist
dictatorship a murdering
dictatorship it's not just some general
anti-government stance that's going on
in cuba
and meanwhile today joe biden frankly
had to be shamed
and barely mustered the courage to give
a short statement in support of those
demanding their freedom from this
murderous regime
one spineless biden state department
official actually lying blaming the
protests on covert 19
quote peaceful protests are growing in
cuba as the cuban people
exercise their right to peaceful
assembly to express
concern about rising covert cases
and medicine shortages well first of all
let's start with the fact that statement
was and is a complete lie
there is no right to assembly in cuba
you'd think the state department of joe
biden might know that
there are no rights in cuba period joe
you might want to tell the people that
work under you if you ever
know what day it is any expression
against the government
in cuba could land you in prison and you
could
end up dead and never to be seen or
heard from again
now that's what these protests are about
not covered
not supply shortages the cuban people
are demanding freedom
over tyranny then press secretary
genesake
she just advances the biden
administration lie that the cuban people
just need a few more vaccines that'll do
it take a look
one of the issues that the that
protesters are
justifiably out there in the streets
protesting about
is hunger is lack of access to vaccines
etc we certainly recognize and
understand that
access to vaccines is one of the issues
that a number of individuals in the
streets is voicing concern about
but we have to determine what the
mechanism would be to work with the
cuban people to get vaccines to them
that's something we're working through
no jen they actually need freedom again
another lie for gutless joe as senator
marco rubio put it quote
protests in cuba are not simply about
shortages
socialism promises guaranteed food
medicine and income
if you give up your freedom and when as
always it fails to deliver
you don't get your freedom back and
that's why the protesters are chanting
liberty senator rubio will join us in a
minute and he's absolutely right
as i have said many times yeah i don't
care socialism communism
authoritarianism whatever historically
whatever name you give it
they promise everything it's all going
to be free free free
sound familiar and the promises always
end in unfulfilled promises of utopia
more poverty that's guaranteed and under
many regimes
death and destruction and then you
calculate after their promises are
broken how much of your personal freedom
did you give up
in the name of what would be uh false
security of the government and in this
case at the hands of an
oppressive dictatorship millions of
cuban people now who immigrated to the
u.s
they know this all too well hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else